you've had uh great success with
perfumes i wanted to bring this up
um
because i don't understand that no one's
ever approached me to develop a scent
uh and i'm just putting it out there if
if anyone's watching but i i no one's
ever come up to me and said development
obviously but you people want you to
develop uh perfumes
but what but what what kind of scent
would you develop like
you know what's your thing
anxiety
flop sweat by conan o'brien yeah
something that just i mean is that what
first of all i don't even understand how
it works they come to you and they say
i mean obviously you're world famous
you're very beautiful and do they ask
you for personality traits or things
that you want to put out there into the
world yeah they ask you me like you know
what's your favorite sense what did you
like as a child what do you like to
smell what do you like to wear and so
it's a lot of you trying out different
yeah
and saying i take a little bit of this i
love a little bit of that
and trying new things myself and really
creating things that i really want to
wear right yeah i would i know somewhere
in there i'd put bacon i would just like
i did that too and they just asked me
what's smelly like i said bacon and they
thought no no no that's not gonna go
over them that would be fantastic i said
the same thing i think i mean dogs would
follow you everywhere but
what's wrong do you develop sense just
for women or well this last one i did is
called closer it's a unisex fragrance so
it's for for a woman but i'm finding men
really like it so you might like it
wait wait a minute you developed wait a
minute you developed it for women but
some men like it and you're saying conan
you really like that
you're pretty much almost like she put
air quotes around some yeah
uh well okay what do are there men that
would
wear these perfumes closer my last one
yeah actually wear it someone my
producer uh
brought brought this for me you're uh on
the on the package right there looking
incredibly beautiful and there's some
she's wearing a tie
yeah
yeah that's true very uh and so this is
the uh this is the scent for women but a
man
could use it should i try i'm gonna just
smell it right now i don't know even how
to do it what are you you're supposed to
spray it and watch it
okay
aren't you supposed to spray it here and
then come through it
but not with your face not with your
face
[Applause]
well i can't see right now
i'm completely
that smells that smells that smells that
smells very nice but it does perfume on
the palm of your hand i don't know what
i'm doing
show me what to do i honestly don't know
where do you put it do you dab a little
what i don't know what to do
you're feel free to touch me anywhere
you want
okay take your pants off okay
[Applause]
like do
it i can't do that andy's you have no
well no it just looked shameful what you
were about the whole dynamic here it was
like you were going to be punished
because
that's my every catholic faith look on
your
face no the way you're supposed to wear
fragrance you're supposed to spray it in
between your thighs
and then it heats up and then the aroma
rises up all day long and when you hug
somebody you don't leave your scent on
them
that's true that's how you're supposed
to wear it
oh my god
never heard that before
i just time traveled while you were
saying that
i went like back to the 1500s